in the last video we had this
differential equation and it at least
looked like it could be exact but we
took the partial derivative of this
expression which we could call M with
respect to why it was different than the
partial derivative of this expression
which is kind of an inexact differential
equations world with respect to it was
different than n with respect to X we
said oh boy it's not exact but we said
what if we could multiply both sides of
this equation by some function that
would make it exact and we call that mu
and in the last video we actually solved
from you we said well if we multiply
both sides of this equation by mu of X
is equal to X it should make this into
an exact differential equation it's
important to note there might have been
a function of Y that if I multiplied by
both sides that would also make it exact
there might have been a function of x
and y that would have done the trick but
you really our whole goal is just to
solve is to make this exact so it
doesn't matter which one we pick which
integrating factor and this is called
the integrating factor which integrating
factor we pick so anyway let's do it now
let's solve the problem so let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
mu which is n mu of X is just X so we
multiply both sides by X so we get C if
you multiply this term by X you get 3x
squared y plus X Y squared plus we're
multiplying this term by these terms by
X now plus X to the third plus x squared
Y y prime is equal to 0
well now first of all just as a reality
check let's make sure that this is now
an exact equation so what's the partial
of this expression or this kind of sub
function with respect to Y well it's
three x squared that's just kind of
constant coefficient on y plus two X Y
that's the partial of with respect to Y
of that expression now let's take the
partial of this with respect to X so we
get three x squared right plus 2xy and
there we have it the
partial of this with respect to Y is
equal to the partial of this with
respect to n so we now have an exact
equation whose solution should be the
same as this all we did is we multiplied
both sides of this equation by X so it
really shouldn't change the solution of
that equation or that differential
equation so it's exact let's solve it so
how do we do that well we say is if
since we've shown this exact we know
that there's some functions I where the
partial derivative of Z with respect to
X is equal to this expression right here
so it's equal to 3x squared y plus X Y
squared let's take the antiderivative of
both sides with respect to X and we'll
get Z is equal to what see it's X to the
third Y plus C X we'll get right 1/2 x
squared Y squared and of course this is
I is a function of x and y so when you
when you take the partial with respect
to X when you go that way you might have
lost some function that's only a
function of Y so instead of a plus C
here there could have been a whole
function of Y that we lost so we'll add
that back when we take the
antiderivative so this is hours I but
we're not completely done yet because we
have to somehow figure out what this
function of Y is and the way we figure
that out is we use the information that
the partial of this with respect to Y
should be equal to this so let's set
that up so what's the partial of this
expression with respect to Y so it would
be so I could write Z the partial of Z
with respect to Y is equal to let's see
X to the third plus c2 times one half so
it's just x squared y plus h prime of Y
right that's the partial of a function
purely of Y with respect to Y and then
that has to equal our new N or the new
expression we got after we multiplied by
the integrating
so that's going to be equal to this
right here this is hopefully be making
sense to you at this point so that
should be equal to X to the third plus x
squared Y and interesting enough these
both of these terms are on this side so
let's subtract both of those terms from
both sides so X to the third X to the
third x squared Y x squared Y and we're
left with H prime of y is equal to 0 or
you could say that you could say that H
of Y is equal to some constant and in in
in the so there's really no there's
really no y
I guess the extra function of Y there's
just some constant left over so for the
for our purposes we can we can just say
that zai is equal to this because this
is just a constant so we're going to
take the antiderivative anyway and get a
constant on the right hand side and in
the previous videos the constants all
merge together so we'll just assume that
that is RSI and we know that this this
differential equation up here can be
re-written as the derivative of Z with
respect to X and that just falls out of
the partial derivative chain rule the
derivative of Z with respect to X is
equal to 0 right if you took the
derivative of Z with respect to X it
should be equal to this whole thing just
using the partial derivative chain rule
well we know what Z is so we can write
or actually we don't even have to we
could use this fact to say well if we
integrate both sides that the solution
of this differential equation is that Z
is equal to C alright I just took the
antiderivative of both sides so a
solution to the differential equation is
AI is equal to C so zai is equal to X to
the third y plus one-half x squared Y
squared and we could have said plus C
here but we know the solution is that Z
is equal to C so we'll just write that
there right I could have write in a plus
C here but then you have a plus C here
and you have another constant there and
they kind you could just subtract them
from both sides and they just merge into
another arbitrary constant but anyway
there we have it we
add a a differential equation that at
least superficially looked exact it
looked exactly the exactness of it it
was not exact but we multiplied it by an
integrating factor and the previous
video we figured out that in a possible
integrating factor is that we could just
multiply both sides by X and when we did
that we tested it and true enough it was
exact and so given that it was exact we
knew that as I would exist
where the derivative of Z with respect
to X would be equal to this entire
expression so we could rewrite our
differential equation like this and we
know that a solution is AI is equal to C
and to solve for Z we just say okay the
partial derivative of Z with respect to
X is going to be this thing
antiderivative of both sides there's
some constant H of Y that constant
there's some function of Y H of Y that
we might have lost when we took the
partial with respect to X so to figure
that out we take this expression take
the partial with respect to Y and set
that equal to our n expression and by
doing that we figured out that that
function of Y is really just it's just
really some constant and we could have
written that here we could have written
that plus C but we know we can call that
C 1 or something but we know that the
solution of our original differential
equation is y is equal to C so the
solution of our differential equation is
sy X third y plus one-half x squared Y
squared is equal to C we could have had
a just you know this plus c1 here and
then subtracted both sides but I think
I've said it so many times and you
understand why I if H of Y is just to
see it you can kind of ignore it anyway
that's all for now and I will see you in
the next video you now know a little bit
about integrating factors see you soon